RAMESH SURAPARAJU:
SAP landscapes
have advanced needs
for backup storage,
especially when you design
high availability and disaster
recovery.
In Google Cloud, there are
many options for backup
to choose from.
What are these options?
Which one is relevant for your
SAP deployment scenario or use
case?
What is unique to Google Cloud?
Hi, I am Ramesh Suraparaju.
And in this video, I will
answer these questions
on backup strategies and
solutions for SAP systems
on Google Cloud.
Customers run mission-critical
business processes
on their SAP systems.
Downtimes must be
kept to a minimum
to ensure business continuity.
Regular backup of data
ensures speedy recovery
from potential data loss.
Google Cloud offers
cost-effective native
capabilities as well as partner
solutions for backup of data.
Before we look at
various backup options,
let us look at a
typical SAP deployment.
Here is the architecture of
SAP deployment on Google Cloud.
The application layer is a set
of one or more SAP NetWeaver
application servers deployed on
Compute Engine with associated
persistent disk storage in a
specific zone within a Google
Cloud region.
The database layer has a
single database server for SAP
and is also deployed on
Compute Engine with associated
persistent disk storage.
Zooming in on the storage
part of this architecture,
we can see that there are a few
specific volumes at file system
level that are
relevant for backup.
In the application layer, these
are the virtual machine boot
disk, the folders for
SAP MNT, and swap space.
At the database layer, the
relevant volumes are, again,
the boot disk, folders
that contain the data
and logs of the database, and
folders that hold the database
backups.
Google Cloud
recommends to separate
these backup relevant
folders from the boot disks
into separate persistent disks.
Google also recommends
that assisted disks
are used, especially for
SAP HANA installations,
due to their performance
and throughput requirements.
HDD can be used for cost
optimization and backup
purposes.
Now let us look at an example
of a centralized S/4HANA
deployment on Google Cloud.
When I select this deployment
in the Google Cloud console
and click on name
of the instance,
we can see the disk layout
for this deployment.
Here you can see the boot
disk of the S4 instance
and all the other
backup-relevant volumes created
and attached to the S4 instance.
Now let me introduce you
to the backup options
for each component of a SAP
installation on Google Cloud.
Persistent disk snapshots
are global resources
that offer a simple and
straightforward way for backup.
Cloud storage buckets offer
regional, dual-region, and
multi-region storage
options that can support
high availability and disaster
recovery architectures of SAP
installations.
Cloud storage also offers
different storage clusters,
like nearline, coldline,
and archive storage,
with rule-based
configuration for time
to live and transitioning
between these storage classes.
Partner solutions for shared
file systems like NetApp,
Cloud volumes also offer
a resilient backup option
using Cloud storage buckets.
Cloud Filestore is a
cost-effective option
for single-zone
SAP installations,
like SAP HANA scale-out,
in a single zone
where high availability is
achieved by standby nodes
within the same zone.
How can these options be
used to back up SAP systems?
At the application layer,
you can schedule PD snapshots
as backup for disks of the SAP
NetWeaver application server.
For multi-instance installations
where a shared file
storage like NetApp
is used, you can
use the features of the
shared file solution
to back up disks to
Cloud storage buckets.
At the database layer 2, you
can schedule snapshots of PDs.
In case of SAP
HANA database, you
can bypass the persistent
disks for HANA backup volumes
and use Backint agent
for Google Cloud
to directly back up to
Cloud storage buckets.
Let me drill down into
the application layer.
This architecture shows a
multi-instance SAP NetWeaver
installation with separate
VMs for primary and additional
application servers, as well
as the central services.
You can see that these
snapshots are created
for each of the
backup-relevant disks,
like the boot disk, SAP MNT,
and the swap space folders.
You can schedule these
snapshots for automating
the backup mechanism
across your SAP landscape.
Now let me show you how
to schedule a snapshot
of a persistent disk.
Here you can see the
existing snapshot schedules
for a centralized two-tier
deployment of a S/4HANA system,
where the database and
application server are all
installed on a single server.
While you can see schedules
exist for boot, swap,
and other disks of
this deployment,
a schedule for backup of
HANA data is still missing.
Let us go ahead and
see how to create one.
Here, I navigate to the
relevant persistent disk, which
is called s4hana-data, and
see that there is no snapshot
scheduled for this disk.
I will proceed to edit the disk
configuration to create one.
Notice that you need not
stop the VM to do this.
Once I am in the Edit
mode of the disk,
I can choose to create
a snapshot schedule
and specify required
configuration like name,
description, location
of the snapshot,
regional or multiregional,
the scheduled frequency,
and start time for
taking the snapshot.
I can also specify
the deletion rules.
In my example, I want
it to be 90 days.
After entering all
parameters, I click Create.
Finally, I save the
disk configuration.
The schedule to take snapshots
for the HANA data disk
is now active.
You can check, in the
snapshot schedules page,
that there is now a new schedule
to back up the HANA data
volume.
Productive SAP
installations often
use shared file storage
in the application layer
to enable faster failover
of application servers.
Shared file solutions,
like NetApp cloud volumes,
also offer configuration
of snapshots
of the shared disks to
Google Cloud Storage buckets.
Let me move on to
the database layer.
If the database
server is SAP HANA,
you have two alternatives.
The first option is
to create schedules
to snapshot the relevant disks
and automate a regular backup
of your database.
Alternative option is to
use the SAP HANA Backint
agent for Google Cloud.
The HANA Backint agent is a
free-of-cost software agent
that can be downloaded
from Google Cloud
to be installed on the VM
that runs your SAP HANA.
Once the Backint
agent is installed,
you can specify the
Cloud storage bucket
into which the backup
files are to be stored.
You can then turn on the options
for catalog and log backup
to use the Backint agent.
Another feature is to enable
parallel backup streams
to decrease backup
times drastically.
When this configuration is
done, your SAP HANA system
and databases will now
use the Backint agent
to back up directly to
Google Cloud Storage bucket.
All the subsequent backups that
are triggered by your SAP HANA
database are directly stored
in the specified Google Cloud
Storage bucket instead
of a file system
folder of a persistent disk.
In this way, you
can bypass the need
to provision a persistent
disk for HANA backup volumes.
Here, you can see the storage
bucket in which the HANA backup
files are stored.
You can see that the systems
and the tenant databases
have separate backup folders.
And of course, you can
restore a database directly
from its bucket location.
To complete the database
layer, this architecture
shows the snapshots scheduled
for all backup-relevant folders
in case of any other
database server,
like Sybase ASE
or MS SQL server.
You can refer to the relevant
database server documentation
for the exact location and
names of the data, log,
and backup folders.
To summarize, Google Cloud
recommends separate disks
for backup-relevant volumes
of your SAP deployment.
You can schedule snapshots
of persistent disks
as primary mechanism for
backup of SAP systems.
Shared file solutions
also support snapshots
to Google Cloud Storage.
You can use SAP HANA Backint
agent for Google Cloud
to bypass persistent disks
for HANA backup volumes.
You can find a lot
more information
about backup options and
solutions for SAP deployments
on Google Cloud at the
links below this video.
Also, please navigate
to cloud.google.com/sap
for information about other
topics related to SAP on Google
Cloud.
Thanks for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]